preuve en est avec nous merci d'être là
sophie alors sophie j'aimerais que tu
nous racontes parce que c'est vrai
qu'après motus ce week-end on a appris
qu'une autre émission emblématique de
france 2 allait s'arrêter il s'agit donc
de c'est au programme
sophie tu es avec nous ce soir en
exclusivité merci d'être là foutu
présente cette émission depuis 1998
alors on va tout à préparer un petit
récapitulatif des faits avait juste un
petit coucou à william leymergie
puisqu'il est sur votre chaise
c'est quand même grâce à lui que j'ai
présenté cette émission parce qu'il m'a
choisi donc pays d'ailleurs il m'a
appelé hier soir six vitres sales super
sympa voix il a une petite et d'un petit
message pour toi vous dire regarde quoi
c'est pas la fin du monde non mais c'est
arrivé à d'autres gardes corps quand
j'ai arrêté était le matin moi aussi
j'aime ça me faisait drôle mais tu as
fait tôt du problème bah cv comme moi tu
en as tellement de bons souvenirs s'est
bien marré non c'était intéressant et
puis j'ai appris tellement de choses
dont tu vas pouvoir te servir encore
plus parce que vraiment et employeurs
ainsi te donne pas quelque chose
d'équivalent ou encore mieux
franchement ça serait une faute
professionnelle non ils vont pas
commettre cette faute l'argent c'est
certain j'ai collé sur les gens bien bon
alors voilà alors si jamais tu as quand
même un petit coup de blues battus fait
comme d'hab tu m'appelles à après 22h 45
tu sais ça ne me coûte ou de bonheur
voilà allez je t'embrasse
et et on a on a aussi d'autres messages
pour toi sophie regarde parce que on a
une petite surprise y en a beaucoup qui
ont voulu te laisser un petit mot ce
soir regarde c'est toi qui m'as pris
d'assaut 21 ans ce n'est pas rien on
arrive on a pleuré en 21 ans étaient mes
côtés cours mais aussi côté jardin ton
sourire ta gentillesse ta disponibilité
vont terriblement me manquer puisque tu
es chili et je sais qu'ils les aiment
teboul est son fils tu es petite
boulette ici absolument génial pourquoi
tu as appelé julien combes est prêt à
tout mais après je viens pour beat d'un
mystère peinture confondues père félix
thiéfaine avec jean félix lalanne t'a
appelé l'ancien ministre jean louis
borloo tu l'a appelé jean-louis borloo
ça fait 13 ans qu'on pose toujours la
question est-ce que je peux avoir la
coupe de cheveux sophie davant que je
peux avoir son blond impossible est-ce
que je peux avoir sa pêche est ce que je
peux avoir sa pétillance encore on fait
de la tv avec sophie davant mesdames
messieurs on est surpris tous les jours
ils vont se marrant tu mets un mot à la
place de l'autre ce que tu fais
régulièrement quand tu touches un peu
délicate mandé
comme ça dix mois cette fois ci je tends
stupide que les jeux internet
qu'est ce que tu en penses j'aimerais
que tu expliques à la france entière
d'où vient ton souvent qu'elle
blanchette
voilà comment tu veux obtenu cg arrivé
au solaire et la d'hector alambic je
t'emmène manger une assiette de frites
quand tu veux parce que j'ai c'est que
c'est empêcher d'y jeter en bas ce film
merci pour tout à bientôt
j'ai tout de même
remerciant diablocs laurence dors lac
damien thévenot roland perez david
arthur luis petirenaud petitrenaud bien
sûr et sophie brafman et damien je
t'embrasse fort mon damien thévenot qui
est qu'il faut bien sûr fichte sont
hyper ému ouais parce que je pense que
c'est ce qui pouvait me faire le plus
plaisir parce que c'est vrai que que ben
21 ans c'est pas rien je les ai
retrouvés tous les jours pendant des
années si une sorte une émission
quotidienne c'est ce que celles ci sont
un feuilleton donc on est dans la vie
des uns des autres tout le jour on se
voit et est ce qui caractérise et cette
émission je pense c'était le respect et
la bienveillance qui avait entre nous
jamais une histoire d'une histoire entre
entre nous quoi alors juste des
précisions parce que kate blanchet sa
demande d'explication
parce que j'étais au festival du cinéma
de deux villes sur le tapis rouge je
suis arrivé un peu à la bourre donc
j'étais seul et tout d'un coup je vois
des flashs partout je me dis tout ça
pour moi je côtoie n'y avait qu'elle
blanchette à côte derrière moi là qui
arrivent et qui devait presser festival
donc alexandre marcellin extrait avec
moi aussi le matin m'a surnommé que mais
toi tu es quesquen revanche attendre
mais benjamin castaldi sa femme
l'appelle comme ces gros pour d'autres
raisons
[Musique]